okay here we go okay I'm pretty sure I'm
shadowing you guys that's like it's like
a horror game he's watching every move
you make right now I got I got to go on
a stroll I got it I got a you know my
legs see anything just a normal day in
the sewers what we gotta go together
what I do buddy what Oh see matters here
too I think I'm gonna take one for the
team you ready you ready Felix okay god
no why did you don't blow me out have
fun in there what the hell
what happened hang on there's no place
something in this point but there is it
now push every single bar all over until
you [ __ ] in bed oh yes
I think this is a bleach okay okay good
make the noise of an ego if you see them
okay no no I'm not a bottle I never wear
a bottle and I never okay I got away I
got away don't worry buddy
I got a watch I gotta wash this [ __ ] I
could you push a chair over to me no
push it over oh I can do that
wait don't laugh seven second check
we're gonna find plenty more plenty more
we'll do what you must have gone this
way you can never know that [ __ ] is one
of us no I'm not the one facing away I
think like the one to your right
no that's what you get [ __ ] t-bag back
oh oh oh
what what's going on here just go away
where are ye Oh where'd you go
I'm just tryin to look outside for him
just in case I could what the [ __ ] are
they freaking out about while you're in
the wrong way I'm just telling you you
are as well you're facing this way
you're facing like that way to me no no
no offense but I would find a hiding
spot if I were you
whoa hey hey I got a great no no no hmm
wait I read it to you there you don't
yeah there you go
no way other side yes no other side
other yes yes no I'm not on it oh you're
not what is going on and where does yeah
yeah yeah you're good you're good going
on I gave you a hit as it went back down
inside the food
Tony can't bear are you that's freaking
spine oh my god it's bursting ah love
it's boiling over all those hiding spot
ever standing atop of me were whoa
Hey he totally so you what are you doing
are you choose object go and choose a
car I don't think he sees me see me
where is he I'll find him
I was in the no health shake just [ __ ]
come on max just do it can't head kill
it I'm a head
okay okay we'll see yeah I have very low
don't touch me
well Jeffrey I have always been very
fond of baking boxes I can tell you're
gonna be good thing I had this crowbar
at the box
why wait don't what
man I don't just make a noise he's not
the box what I am he's very good at
bluffing like me I just donated OPA Oh
what they destroyed it wait a second
what don't you dare touch that bike I
just want to go on a bike ride
ah this is so nice only I could drive
you away if only I could kill it was it
alright bro I hope you enjoyed this prop
hunt montage go ahead and leave a like
if you did hit subscribe to become a bro
today and thanks for hitting 13.5
million already that's crazy
go ahead and click here to watch more
montages or click here to watch more
profit videos stay awesome bros
you